[Music]
Parliament has begun a marathon series
of hearings of nominees to the European
Commission first up were Maris F kovitch
Phil Hogan and Maria Gabrielle they've
been put forward for the positions of
inter institutional relations trade and
innovation the committee's on
constitutional affairs and on legal
affairs question matter set kovitch a
former MEP the Slovak is currently a
commission vice-president he's been
nominated as commissioner for inter
institutional relations and Forsyte MEP
s questioned him on how to include
citizens in the future of Europe and the
parliaments role in that future
especially on Parliament's right to
initiate legislation after SEF kovitch
committed to taking on board any peace
proposals for new laws of formal rights
currently only enjoyed by the Commission
a stronger Parliament means a stronger
and more legitimate Europe a stronger
Parliament also means moving into a
shared culture of anticipation and
action to be resilient in the long run
Phil Hogan from Island has been put
forward for the position of trade
commissioner he previously served in the
Irish government and is currently EU
commissioner for agriculture any peas
from the Committee on international
trade questioned him on growing
protectionism around the world relations
with China or the US and how European
trade deals could be better implemented
they also questioned him on how to
ensure a level playing field in digital
commerce Europe needs to be the global
champion of fair sustainable and
rules-based trade with your help I
believe we can strengthen that
leadership role we can act and deliver
results that show the European Union at
his best if confirmed Hogan will be the
--use chief negotiator on international
trade negotiations and will represent
the EU at the WTO next up was the
Bulgarian Maria Gabrielle for the post
of Commissioner for innovation and huge
the industry research and energy
committee teamed up with the Committee
on culture
and education to question her a former
MEP Gabrielle is the current
commissioner for digital economy and
society
did it work MEP focused their
questioning on the protection of
cultural diversity and exchange program
such as horizon 2020 and Erasmus the
vote in Parliament's to decide if the
Commission as a whole is accepted or
rejected is scheduled for the 23rd of
October
[Music]